hi I'm Erik Bosse and once upon a time
in Hollywood is Quentin Tarantino's
ninth film in which cutie delivers
everything fans appreciate from his
unique style and Bleen cruises around la
streets killer soundtrack feet sudden
bursts of ultra violence and interesting
relationship with actual history and
feet but really it is the ending of this
movie that has the most people talking
but before I continue spoiler warning
once upon a time in Hollywood is really
worth experiencing the way it was meant
to be in a theater filled with people
cheering for blood way too much really
this breakdown is just to give people
more background on this ending after
they've already seen it to go watch it
okay so when Tarantino first announced
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood a few
years back he said that this movie would
revolve around the infamous murders of
actress Sharon Tate and her associates
by the Manson Family in 1969 Tarantino's
films are said and kind of an alternate
fictional reality in which many have
described as an interconnected Tarantino
cinematic universe go horn honks as we
saw with inglorious basterds and Django
Unchained the directors latter films
seem to have this kind of altered
history correcting dark historical
wrongs in the directors eyes to instead
provide Hollywood style happy endings to
these events but unlike the endings of
those past two films Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood's ending is less of a victory
lap with this ending Tarantino wants us
to feel more somber and to question the
nature of the Hollywood Indian itself so
in real life Sharon Tate played by
Margot Robbie in this film and several
others were brutally murdered after
midnight on August 9th 1969 in their
Hollywood Hills home by followers of
Charles Manson it was a horrific crime
that some historians and culture critics
have described as the death of the 1960s
in America leading to a more somber
cynical 1970s when people began locking
their doors and began to feel
increasingly desensitized to violence
mostly violence in the media but once
upon a time in Hollywood is Tarantino's
fairy tale retelling of these events and
so he gives us a fairy tale ending
inserting into real history the
fictional characters of actor Rick
Dalton and his stuntman driver cliff
Booth who derail and prevent the Manson
family from affecting history this way
by essentially doing to them what these
intruders were planning to do to Sharon
Tate so what was the real history of
these murders and how does Tarantino's
film alter that history and set up the
big twist
well some background detail in case you
didn't know
Charles Manson was a struggling musician
and ex-con in Hollywood in the 1960s who
attracted a gang of mostly female
followers a cult dubbed the Manson
Family one music producer who rejected
Charles Manson was named Terry Melcher
who lived in a house at one zero zero
five zero Cielo Drive in the Hollywood
Hills a house that would later be rented
by Roman Polanski the young hotshot
director of Rosemary's Baby and his wife
actress and model Sharon Tate along with
a close friend of theirs hairstylist Jay
Sebring early in Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood Charles Manson makes his one
appearance in the film visiting the
Cielo drive house looking for Meltzer so
this establishes how he knows it's now
occupied by celebrities which will play
into his dark master plan later on now
in real life Manson and his followers
actually briefly associated with Dennis
Wilson of the Beach Boys
Wilson picked up two hitchhiking Manson
family women Patricia KRENWINKEL who was
one of the tape murderers and Ella Joe
Bailey bringing them back to his place
which then shortly after became occupied
by Manson himself in the whole gang
until some time later when Wilson's
manager shooed them all away once upon a
time in Hollywood in a way swaps cliff
Boothe into this role
cliff picks up the hitchhiker pussycat
and drives her to the spawn ranch
essentially Dennis Wilson and cliff
booths mistake is the origin of the wise
words of Jack Donaghy never go with a
hippie to a second location as depicted
in the film the spawn ranch was the
actual residence of the Manson family
after their time with Wilson it was
formerly used to shoot TV and film
westerns until falling into disrepair in
the late 60s and thereafter used mostly
to give horseback riding tours the
Manson Family helped maintain this ranch
with Lynette squeaky Fromme played by
Dakota Fanning in this movie
accompanying George spawn played by
Bruce Stern who is now an old sick blind
man George gave her the nickname of
squeaky because of the sound she made
Winnie pinched her thigh squeaky Fromme
would later go on to try to assassinate
President Gerald Ford in 1975 yeah this
is a pretty messed up group of people so
in the movie cliff once a stuntman in
westerns knows this ranch and he
recognizes that something is off about
the Manson family's occupation of it and
when one of these hippies flattens his
tire he Wallops them in the face now at
this point Tarantino has established
cliff as a mythologized Hollywood
superhero we've learned via flashbacks
that cliff can't get work because of
rumors that he shot his wife off a boat
with a harpoon gun somehow got away with
it
and
cliff got into a fight with Bruce Lee on
set a fight that cliff was winning
before it was stopped see folks in
Hollywood the closest thing we have to
realize superheroes are these stunt
performers they take the physical
beatings that make these movies so
thrilling to watch so when cliff punches
people they literally fly off their feet
he's ripped he's trained at the best dog
in the world with dog food labeled
Wolf's tooth great for angry dogs he's
the kind of unstoppable force of human
nature that the bride and Django are but
in the story's main narrative Tarantino
works and other self-references to hint
at this coming twist revisionist history
with the character of Rick Dalton a
struggling actor desperate to cling to
the moderate success that he's gained
you'll notice that one of his past film
roles was to torch Nazis with a
flamethrower similar to the fiery climax
of inglorious basterds which gave World
War 2 a happy ending it tells us that
Tarantino has something similar in mind
for the tape murders so as we head into
this film's final act all the pieces are
in place for Tarantino to subvert
history Kurt Russell's voiceover walks
us through the timeline of the day of
August 8th 1969 he explains how on that
day Sharon Tate was eight and a half
months pregnant that Roman Polanski was
away shooting a film in Europe Tate and
Jay Sebring were joined by Polanski's
friend voytek frykowski and Abigail
Folger heiress to the Folger Coffee
Empire now in real life music producer
Quincy Jones was supposed to have joined
them too but he decided earlier not to
go this movie establishes that Rick and
cliff were out drinking that night and
then they came home to watch one of
Rick's recent TV guest spots and then
cliff took his dog brandy for a walk
smoking an acid dipped cigarette he got
from pussycat earlier and then he passed
his four members of the Manson Family
Tex Watson
Sadie Atkins Patricia KRENWINKEL whom
they referred to as Katie and Linda
Kasabian
whom they refer to his flower child now
she's played by Maya Hawke recently seen
in stranger things and real-life
daughter of Ethan Hawke and longtime
Tarantino collaborator uma Thurman now
in real life Manson had order text to go
to the Meltzer house and murder everyone
inside and to make it as gory as
possible the goal of the four murderers
and the real plan of Charles Manson was
to murder these Hollywood elites and
then blame it on the Black Panthers and
then from their insight and apocalyptic
race war that they called helter skelter
yeah
but in the movie as they start to scope
out the house neighboring Rick runs out
in the coldest sack in his bathrobe
cusses out the hippies shoes them away
because we've seen how at this point his
career he's struggling to hold on to
whatever pieces of success he has
including his Hollywood Hills home so
that he is that much more protective
over his property against these kind of
outsiders
so the Manson's changed their plan they
recognize rick as the gunslinger JK hill
from the bounty law TV show and they
decide to murder him instead since his
TV and movie roles taught them the
violence that has now corrupted their
minds yeah it's kind of [ __ ] but
it's the kind of narrative that they
think will spread and work so as they
walk up to Rick's house flower child
Kassabian flees back to the car and
takes off now in real life Kassabian
stayed behind to keep watch as the other
three trespassed on to the grounds and
then text murdered a visiting friend of
the property caretaker and then the
three broke into the house and they
murdered tate and her unborn child and
Folger Sebring for Kowski stabbing all
of them multiple times and then writing
pig on the wall and Tate's blood yes
these true events were awful in
Tarantino uses the public knowledge of
these infamous crimes in order to build
tension setting us up with dread of
these characters destined ends but then
releases that tension by altering
history in a huge way so in Tarantino's
fictional happy ending none of these
tragedies occur and not only are Tate
and the others rescued we feel rescued
from having to witness those deaths text
ad and Katy break into Rick's home and
cliff tripping on acid recognizes them
from the ranch text tells cliff the
words I am the devil and I'm here to do
the devil's business which is apparently
the exact words that text spoke to for
Kowski in the Tate house and as text
prepares to kill cliff all hell breaks
loose cliff shucks the heavy dog food
can at one of their faces these signals
brandy the dog to attack Tex he takes
another one just like smashes her face
on every surface over and over almost as
if Tarantino was echoing the excessive
overkill of the Manson's actual murders
Ric finishes off the last one in the
pool tortured her with his old
flamethrower the one stunt he did
himself he mentioned earlier how he
practiced for hours and hours just like
in the movies folks a stuntman does all
the heavy lifting and the star comes
at the last second to get the glory shot
now you may have noticed how as the
credits roll the theme song of the 1960s
Adam West Batman series is playing this
is a callback to Al Pacino's earlier
meeting with Rick joking that Rick could
one day do some Batman style action bang
zoom Zoey and indeed this climax
fulfills that destiny with Rick as
Batman and his insane over-the-top
gadgetry in cliff as the Boy Wonder
unleashing cartoonish violence but it is
the final scene that separates Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood from the ultra
violence and historical revisionism of
Tarantino's other work after the cops
and ambulance pulled off Rick turns any
chats with Jay Sebring in the driveway
and he finally gets to meet Sharon Tate
a dream that he had brought up earlier
see in this film Rick represents the old
Hollywood westerns and TV procedurals
that were dying out in the late 60s Tate
and Polanski were part of the young new
Hollywood well before Tate's life was
tragically cut short but in this happy
ending old new come together in these
hypothetical new lives that they get to
live but over the sweet imagery the
title once upon a time in Hollywood
appears reminding us that this is a
false fairy tale a sugar-coated revision
of one of the darkest nights in
Hollywood history
Hollywood being the land known for its
sugar-coated fairy tales so this ending
fills us not with the glee and
righteousness that the what-if endings
of inglourious basterds and Django and
Shane did but rather fills us with a
sense of melancholy sadness over the
star that Sharon Tate could have been
and should have been known as instead of
the victim that the history books now
describe so in these final moments
Tarantino reminds us that this sadly is
not the world that we live in and that
Hollywood actually does not reflect life
as it is but rather it's a heightened
reflection that provides escapism and
catharsis and that it's the role of
cinema in Tarantino's mind at least to
transport us into the fictionalized
dreamland and to end with dramatic
awakenings from that dream so did Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood's Indian leave
you with the payoff that you felt after
inglorious basterds and Django Unchained
and how did this film rank among all of
Tarantino's films for you I'm curious to
know your thoughts comment down below
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA vas and subscribed in new rock
stars for breakdowns and theories about
everything you love thanks for watching
and hey if you clicked
this video for the beat let's not use
the comments to back-channel those links
because I don't kink shame but I do the
link shame cool cool
[Music]